[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نحتفل الفيديو
يكون ذكرى تكون
انا مشكلتي الوحيده مع الفيديو هذا انه
بالشباح
ما هو بصراحه انا ما كنت عارف اني في يوم
من الايام رح اطلع اوقف على مسرح قدام
الناس واقعد اعلق عليه بس اللي كنت عارفه
مامن فيه ان في يوم من الايام راح اوصل
على مكاني منيح والمكان اليوم اللي انا
فيه بالنسبه لي انا نجاح انا مبسوط جدا
فيه
شكرا
طبعا بالفيديوهات انا كنت طالب هندسه سنه
ثانيه
السؤال ليش هندسه بتعرفوا هاي اللحظه اللي
بتيجي بدك تكتب فيها على الورقه ايش
التخصص اللي بده ينبنى عليه مستقبلك
واحلامك والحياه كلها
فبطلع صوتين صوت قلبك بحكي لك الحق حلمك
وشغفك وانت ايش بتحب تعمل وفي صوت عقلك
المنطقي اللي ادرس هيك عشان تاخد القده
وتوصل للقده انا سمعت صوت حالي
حالي كان مغترب برا البلد فهو متطور عنا
دائما يعني كان اول واحد عمل ايميل
فاجا قعد معي قال لي شو بدك تدرس قلت له
والله ما انا عارف انا يعني بحكوا لي اني
دمي خفيف وبضحك قال لي يا زلمه شو هالحكي
الفاضي بدنا ناكل عيش يعني شو اللي فيه
هندسه اسمها هندسه معدات طبيه
تمام اول مره بسمع بالتخصص في حياتي انا
قال لي عاده بتعمل هيك بتساوي هيك اقنعني
او ضحك علي جد ما بعرف بس انا اقتنعت
رحت بدي احكي لابوي وبقول لي ابوي شو شو
قررت قلت له والله خلص هندسه معدات طبيه
قال لي متاكد قلت له اه يا زلمه مستقبلها
منيح وانا شايف حالي فيها
فاول مره كنت بحس جد قديش ابوي دبلوماسي
تركلي راحتي حكى لي المهم انت تكون مبسوط
مع انه انا فايت الهندسه بمعدل دفش يعني
معدل الهندسه القبول 80 انا جايب 80
وعشرين يعني مش مهندس مهندس
فتطلع للمعدل
يعني بدنا ندفع موازي واحنا عيله متوسطه
فمش هاي القدره العاليه انه والله
تفشل بس يعني كسرنا القواعد امي كان
بالنسبه لها انه ابنها بده يصير مهندس
واختيار تخصص اخوها فاكيد هذا احسن تخصص
في العالم
وبدها تجاهر جارتنا ام خالد كان ابنها
مهندس فبدها تورجيها انه يزن احسن من خالد
المهم سجلت هندسه ورحت على الجامعه
كنت اروح مبسوط عشان بس بدي اقعد مع الناس
يعني يكون عندي محاضرات اي واحد يحكي لي
اسمع شو رايك نقعد اروح اقعد انا واياه
صار الناس يلتموا علي بالجامعه اقعد احكي
ويضحكوا وهذا الشيء يعني شعور انه انا
احكي اشي والناس بتضحك وشكرا لكم تضحكوا
الشعور هذا ببسطني يعني هذا الشيء اللي
بحركني من جوا
قضينا على الفصل نروح نقعد مع الشباب نضحك
ونروح نضحك ونروح ما كنت عارف ان الموضوع
رح يقرب بحزن
طلعوا العلامات
طبعا المعدل الجامعه من اربعه كنا عارفين
انا معدلي طلع واحد ونص
انا معدل طلع صفر فاصله ثمانيه
يعني من 122 منخفض درجه حراره هاي مش معدل
شو بدي اعمل الزلمه دافع ابوي بيسالني كيف
الجامعه
بالمناسبه ابوي وامي هون فتحيه
قال لي الواحد يكسب اخرته يعني وخطيبتي
كمان هون بدي اكسب الدنيا كمان
شكرا شكرا
شو
[تصفيق]
شكرا شكرا
المهم روحت على البيت انا يعني مش عارف
كيف بدي اروح بس روحت شو كيف العلامات
للاسف اضطريت اني اخبي الموضوع قلت له لا
تمام كله تمام قال لي يعني الامور تمام
اشوف علاماتك بتشكك في ابنك
طلع فيها انه لا مش لازم اكسر الثقه فقال
لي خلاص تمام
حسيت بخيبه امل انه يعني اهلي مش هالناس
المرتاحين بدرسوني موازي وانا قاعد انا
حملت كل المواد الا عربي 99 يعني تنجح
فيها انك بتنطق اصلا
فمن هون حكيت لا لازم اغير لازم ادرس
واتعب وفعلا صرت اروح على الجامعه احضر
محاضراتي صحيح ما كنتش افهم اشي بس انا
كنت أروح احضر احاول اقعد مع الشباب اسمع
اتعلم
اجت علامات الفصل الثاني من اربعه جبت صفر
فاصله سته
انا عارف انه اي يمكن ما تكونش علاء هاي
علامه من علامات الساعه او او علامه انه
شو بتعمل هون حول هذا المكان مش الك
شو بدي اعمل شو بدي اعمل احكي مع الشباب
اللي يقول لي اسمع هاجر بدنا نتصرف بعدين
حسيت انه ممكن تكون المشكله بالجامعه مش
فيه صحيح او درس بالهاشميه تحياتي تحياتي
لا يزعلش انام لاخر الحوار كلكم راح
ترفعوا ايديكم قد ما لفيت جامعات
المهم قلت خلاص بنقل الجامعه بروح على
الجامعه خاصه بلكي كان الوضع اسهل شوي
المهم رحت على الجامعه الخاصه
ممتاز ممتاز ما تخافيش انا متاكد اني دارس
في جامعه اكيد انت فيها راح ترفعي ايدك
رحت على الجامعه والله بلشت ادرس اقعد مع
الشباب هيك وكان لاول مره في حياتي بنجح
بفصلي كامل
لاول مره
والاخيره طبعا كانت
بهذا الوقت انا صورت الفيديوهات هذا
الفيديو انا ما بنسى التاريخ اللي صورته
فيه كان
14/12/2015 14 14 12 شهر شتاء ليش لابس
سنه في الشباح الله يسامحك المهم
صورت هذا الفيديو كنت مامن بحالي اني انا
دمي خفيف والناس دائما بتضحك علي فليش ما
اصور هذا الشيء وانزله والشباب صراحه
اصحابي ولاد عمتي كانوا يشجعوني انه يزن
صوروا نزل ولسه وقتها 2015 ما كانت هاي
الموجه من الانفلونسرز موجوده او الناس
على السوشيال ميديا فالمستقبل مجهول انا
ما بعرف شو بده يصير بس انا ضامن اني على
اساس بدرس هندسه فشو ما صار معي هاي
الهندسه هون
وبلشت الحياه تمشي والمحتوى يكبر والدراسه
تبعد اكثر الموضوع بكبار دراسه بتبعد اكثر
وابوي بستنى بس
لحد
سنه رابعه فصل تاني
قعدت وانا بحاول اني اقنع حالي اني انا
ممكن اكون مهندس اربع سنين ونص
وما كانت تزبط لحد ما في يوم من الايام
اجتني رساله في صبيه كانت بعتيت لي انها
بدها تشتغل معي اعملها دعايه لشغل انا ما
فتحت المسج طلعت على الجامعه مروح انا
وصاحبي وجهت بيته تلفوني بيرن
رديت مرحبا كيف الحال معك دعاء انا كنت
قارئ اسمها الصبح فربطت دعاء كيف جبتي
رقمي قالت لي العصفوره حكتلي ما اخذت فيها
قالت لي حابين نعمل معك اجتماع اذا بتحب
نجتمع اخر الاسبوع قلت لها انا ما كان فيه
في جيبتي لاخر الاسبوع الخمس دنانير فقلت
لها انا ما بقدر اجي اخر الاسبوع انا
مشغول عملت حالي فنان وهيك بس بقدر اذا
بدك هلا
قالت لي هلا هلا سحبت حالي ورحت عندها فتت
تعرفت عليها
واشتغلت معها بعدين صارت تحكي لي مين
بساعدك مين برد على الايميلات تبعتك مين
قلت لها والله يعني حسب مين بكون فاضي
بقول له
قالت لي خلاص اذا بتصير كل فتره تيجي عندي
انا برد على الايميلات وبساعدك بالمناسبه
هي اليوم مديره اعمالي فاي حدا
لا لا انا مش بحكي عشان انا بحكي عشان اذا
حدا بده اي دعايه هي موجوده
فكنت كل ما اروح عندها تتمسخر علي اني لسه
بدرس هندسه مش عشان الهندسه تخصص سيء ولكن
اشي مش مناسب الي وانا هي كانت كنت بحكي
لها ايش بصير معي بالجامعه وكيف ابوي
بستنى وام خالد بتستنى ويعني فحكت لي ادرس
التخصص
اللي كل يوم تصحى من النوم متحمس انك بدك
تشتغله او بدك تعمله فهل هي الهندسه جوابي
كان بيني وبين حالي مش الها طبعا لا فباي
اللحظات تاكدت اني انا ما بدي اكمل هندسه
سحبت حالي رحت على الجامعه كنت بلشت تطلع
لي شويه فلوس فيعني وراح اقدر اشيل مشوار
جديد تخصص جديد لحالي
درست تخصص
اسمه كان
اشي زنائي
وكنت مبسوط كنت اروح كانت المواد باول فصل
هي الاساسيات اعداد ممثل
تصوير كتابه سيناريو وكنت اروح متحمس يعني
كان الفصل هذا كانه فصل الربيع بالنسبه لي
الجو حلو وسعيد
اسالوا بعد العصر
هذا الفصل بس ضليت مخبي هذا الموضوع عن
اهلي
الاهليه لسه بالاهليه
بعدين بنص الفصل الجامعه هيك عملت تغيير
التخصص راح لمكان تاني صار اسمه ديكور
السينما انا بديش ادرس ديكور انا بدي امثل
بدي اعرف في الميكينج يعني مش مكاني هذا
طب شو بدي اعمل شو ليش هيك بصير مش فاهم
ولا برن علي صديق الي طبعا هو هلا وزيره
معاه الوزير احمد
بوجه له تحيه لانه هذا الشخص امن فيي
كان وقتها لسا بشتغل بشركه اتصالات حكى لي
تعال بدنا نعمل مع بعض شغل شو بتعمل
بحياتك قلت له والله انا قصتي مع الجامعه
واحد اثنين ثلاثه وصار هيك التخصص عارف شو
اعمل ارجع هندسه ولا ادرس اشي مش حابه قال
لي في جامعه اسمها اس اي مختصه في المجال
هذا عن بعطوا منح روح قدم والله انا ما
كذبت خبر سحبت حالي ورحت قدمت طلعت لي
منحه كامله
طلعت لي منها كامله طبعا انا لساتني مخبي
الموضوع على اهلي وابوي بيسال كيف الجامعه
تمام يا حاج امي بتجهز هندسه بتجهز هلا
للزفه وتخريج خلص انا المفروض بدي اتخرج
في اول يوم رحت فيه على الجامعه كانوا
جايبين تلفزيون يغطي تصوير اول يوم في
الجامعه
فانا فايت يكشفتهم بصوره تخبيت وعامل حاله
مش تمام ولا بقول يزن تعال احنا اعطيناك
قال لي بدك تطلع في المقابله قلت له وحد
الله شو بدي اقعد اقول له ابوي والجماعه
معطيني منحه بقدرش قلت انا بطلع من هون
لايمنتجوا المواد اللي عم باخذوها ويطلع
الاشي هذا بكون انا تصرفت يعني مع ابوي
يعني
خلصتها اللقاء بطلع على تلفوني سته
وثلاثين ابوي
35 الف مسكول امي
واخواني كلهم باعثين مسجات اهرب ترجعش على
البيت يعني
كانه كنا طالعين مباشر الموضوع ما بعرف
كيف وصل الخبر طبعا انا قررت اني بدي اروح
اواجه مصيري خلاص رايح على البيت وايدي
على قلبي وخفان عقلي بالعاده امي انا
بتفتح الباب فتحت لي ام خالد جارتنا
اجتماع في الحاره كلها
فتت لقيت ابوي قاعد
حاطط هيك اشي ابيض انا ما فهمت بس
واوعيه عشان تكون جاهز انك خلص انت ماخذ
اواعيك وطالع
انا على البيت بقول لي شو اللي سمعناه شو
هاد قلت له
يابا انا بدي الحق حلمي حلمي احنا بندفع
لنا سنين قلت له لا انا اخذت منها طلع في
هيك قال لي منحه قلت له قال لي الف مبروك
بابا حبيبي
كنت اول مره بعرف انه مادي لهالدرجه
ومن هون الحياه تغيرت اخذت لي مكان ثاني
اسست شركه انتاج عملت سبعه وثمانيه على
التلفزيون صار عندي متابعين على السوشيال
ميديا صرت كل مكان الناس تشوفني تحكيلي
شكرا على المحتوى اللي بتعمله هذا الاشي
لمسني انا كنت مكتئب وضحكني فهذا الشعور
كان جد هذا اللي بدور عليه اه انا بدي
اصحى كل يوم من النوم عشان اعمل هيك
فنصيحتي لاي حدا اذا بدك تنجح في الحياه
هي خلطه بسيطه لازم تامن بحالك لانه اذا
ما انت امنت بحالك ما حدا راح يامن فيك
لازم تسمع صوت قلبك وشو اللي بتحبه وما
تسمع صوت خالك
لازم تسعى باللي بتقدر عليه ولحالها
الامور بتمشي انت مش مطلوب منك تعرف كيف
بدها تمشي ثلاث اللحظه هاي حاول صورها
ويستحسن بالشباح وان شاء الله انكم
بتنجحوا وشكرا كتير يعطيكم العافيه شكرا
شكرا شكرا
[موسيقى]